nuevos medios nacionales lo califican
como el día más oscuro de la presidencia
de joe biden tras el acto terrorista que
más muertes a soldados estadounidenses
ha causado en afganistán desde el 2011
rompí y los republicanos que se
eligieron bajo la promesa de acabar
guerras interminables en irak y
afganistán y gobernaron cuatro años sin
retirar las tropas ahora están
criticando fuertemente al presidente
yobái del por la forma como está
manejando la situación este ataque no
hubiera ocurrido si yo fuera presidente
dijo donald trump en fox news sin
embargo hay que recordar que fue el ex
presidente quien firmó un acuerdo con
los talibanes para que a cambio de no
atacar las tropas estadounidenses hasta
mayo del 2020 el liberar a 5000
talibanes son también dijo que él había
acabado con el estado islámico grupo que
mató al menos a 12 estadounidenses en
los ataques al aeropuerto en cabo